[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where dad
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they really love and create actual
amazing relationships
christina ellis number one best-selling
author ramsey personalities my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
your life and your money the call is
free and some say the advice is worth
exactly what you pay for it the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five we're
gonna start off with scott this hour in
fort lauderdale hey scott how are you
i'm good dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so i work for a uh for a company that i
get 10 of my salary the ability to
purchase company stock um the stock has
been very very fruitful over the 10
years that i've worked for the company
the way our stock purchase works is that
we get
to purchase the 10 of our salary twice a
year in a six month period
at 15 percent below the lowest point in
that six month period
so the the
the sometimes when i get these the stock
at the six months it can be forty fifty
dollars a share better than the market
value at the time
when i read baby steps millionaire in
the money makeover
you talk more about putting your
retirement into mutual funds i've kind
of considered that 10
as being
my part of my retirement
of i take 16 out of my total salary with
six percent in a 401k that that my
company matches
and then the other 10
is in company stock
um and the stock has done nothing but
gain in the in the nine years that i've
been there and it's some big jumps as
well
so do i leave that in there and consider
that that
still ten percent of my retirement
or do i switch it like you talk about in
the money makeover to mutual funds
well congratulations
sounds like you've hit a home run man
uh it feels kind of good
and so um yeah the your theory has not
been stress tested yet
and uh that'll come along okay first let
me give you a couple observations first
uh number one your company stock
purchase plan is no different than most
of them
they're almost all exactly what you
described 15 below lowest to the six
month average whatever okay uh and so
it's not like you're getting some huge
discount that other people that have uh
the work for a publicly traded company
with stock options don't get it's almost
always exactly what you outline
very very similar if not so uh it's good
but it's not the biggest deal in most
cases if you look at a 52-week high
52-week low on the charts you will see a
move of
most stocks more than 15 percent up or
down and so that fifteen percent
discount can as you said cause because
it's down cause a uh a great purchase
price but also can cause um you know it
can evaporate in about an eye blink uh
just because of the normal volatility of
stock uh observation number one
observation number two single stocks are
more risky
than mutual funds
okay period
no exceptions
because you're you're violating the
diversification rule and you know you
got all your eggs in one basket or at
least that number of eggs are all in
that one basket um and so it's you're
taking more risk even though
you've had the benefit of this company
doing very well it's gone up gone i've
gone up i'm happy for you i'm glad it
went up i don't want you to have hard
times uh but uh
but that can that can gloss over the
fact that you're taking risks because
you haven't had a loss
you're not anything that scared you that
woke you up like oh this is risky so
what we tell folks to do our standard
rule of thumb
is uh don't put more than 10 of your net
worth in single stocks
and you currently have more than that
with the formula you're giving me
okay
okay so the example of that always comes
back to my mind was many years ago i was
coaching a lady that worked for procter
gamble which is a fine company she had
eight hundred thousand dollars in her
401k it was all in
company stock
it went in half the year she retired
so i don't none of my 401k is in i work
for apple is in apple stock oh
wonderful stock yeah
the the stock purchase is a total
separate deal and to be honest with you
dave i i haven't um
i'm recently divorced a couple of years
and i was
um lucky to get out and be debt free and
you know i never really read your books
because i never had any i didn't have
any debt but after watching you with
robert morris i uh i've downloaded the
first book and then went to the second
book and it really motivated me to kind
of get my
act together yeah well
ecclesiastes says
spread your portions to seven yes to
eight for disaster may come upon the
land
and apple is about as
uh
it's about as wonderful a single stock
story as there is on the planet
yeah
it's doubled it's this double oh it's
crazy
we'd have to get rid of some of it they
have more money than each other
they really do
they actually have more cash than egypt
it's an incredible company
hey you mentioned you read the first two
books and that you originally had kind
of stayed away because you weren't in
debt but i recommend you pick up baby
step millionaires that's what you're
talking about oh perfect well i did i
did i read no i read both of the books
i've actually listened to probably
probably three times each well thank you
um so the whole question is do you how
much risk do you want to take and and i
think we can all stand up and cheer and
say apple has done a wonderful job of
all the single stocks out there
it's the one that might be the most
tempting it is an unbelievable story uh
but i still i'm just risk averse enough
to say okay i'm going with a scripture
says spread my portions to seven yes to
eight i don't want my whole deal on one
company
and you don't have your whole deal but
you got a lot of it
and so i'm probably gonna be a little
less apple prone if i'm you if i was
ever gonna do what you're doing it would
be that company oh my god it's wonderful
okay so you know if you want to keep
doing it keep doing it i just want you
to hear a lot i want you to feel
that you're you're violating the
diversification principle
and that does nothing but increase risk
inherently in that
one bad iphone launch
one bad lawsuit over a tablet or
whatever i don't know what could happen
i mean i have no idea what can happen
but you know it's they get cancelled
cultured i don't know i don't know how
this works but whatever it is i just
don't want it's not in your control
you're one of a bazillion employees you
don't control this stock
and so i i
i wouldn't be as heavy in it as you are
but i will acquiesce and say if i was
ever going to be
good lord there you know the the the
financial numb regardless of what you
think of the products or the people or
anything else the financials on that
company are blistering good
yeah that's a great position to be in
it's crazy yeah it's crazy how much cash
they have
it's mind-blowing but yeah but aside
from that i still
well i mean
i'm sitting here saying how much i'm a
fanboy of their stock
and i don't own a single share
[Music]
that says i follow the principles i
don't buy single stocks at all and if i
was going to it wouldn't be more than 10
percent of my net worth don't it just
you can do what you want to do but i'm
not doing it thanks for the call
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free
whitepaper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
guys if you are in the chicken little
camp
where you think the sky is falling
you're in the right place we sell
helmets
we're here to help it's uh it's not
falling the apocalypse is not here the
housing market's not going to crash this
is not 2008
and even if it was you would survive it
i did and many others did
i know
it's not what you're hearing on the news
because there's a lot of politics
underlying
a lot of news reports like all of them
one side or the other they're trying to
trump up or drum up or dumb down or
whatever it is they do so click baits in
the headlines you're gonna die
yeah you're not um not from that anyway
you gotta look at the facts most of
what's happening is simple supply and
demand
there's a huge spike in home buying
demand in the last couple of years
weren't enough houses prices go up
housing slows down demand slows down
prices even out they quit going up so
fast
if there's a whole lot less demand like
if nobody's buying houses and there's an
oversupply of inventory then prices will
go down
however inventory is one-fourth of what
it was in 2008 and demand is currently
4x
so there would have to be a dramatic
shift for prices to go down calm down
if you haven't seen it we want you to
watch it you can watch the replay of the
ramseysolutions.com event that rachel
cruz george campbell and i did
about the real estate market the real
estate reality check ramseysolutions.com
slash reality check it is completely
free it's about an hour no it's exactly
an hour long i actually ended up hitting
the clock oddly enough
and uh which with a live stream you
don't have to do but i did it anyway so
there you go
uh they were airing it on tbn and it
helped tbn to hit the clock i told them
i'm not sure if we'll hit the clock or
not but we'll try and then i had a clock
up there and i'm radio guy i just ended
up hitting it that's impressive well i
don't know it might be somewhat
accidental but
um like we ran out of stuff to say or
something like that but if we had a lot
more to say we'd have kept yacking but i
think i think we had said it so there
you go
uh
jump in here the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
beth from michigan emails in a question
does a life insurance policy end when
the term is over
or can i renew it indefinitely if i
renew will the price go up
oh good question you we definitely
recommend term life insurance usually
you establish that on the front end
10-year 15-year 20-year term and
typically i believe you correct me if
i'm wrong dave that you have to renew if
you finish that term you got to go
through the medical underwriting again
just to make sure that you're in good
health and to get a new term
most term
is renewable you can buy what's called
renewable term and it can some of that
is renewable without medical some of it
will require medical depending on what
it is how expensive it is but if you
have a five year term basically the
policy is a for a term of five years it
ends in five years and the price you
will be older in five years so the price
will go up because you're older
and the older you are statistically the
more likely you are to die
so life insurance goes up as you get
older and so if you have an art an
annual renewable term it goes up every
year because you get older every year
we recommend 15 to 20-year level term
insurance because what they've done is
they've averaged out the number of times
people drop a policy by a policy
don't renew a policy all that kind of
stuff and
a 20-year level term is cheaper than the
average of
20 years of annual renewable term
okay you would think that and because
annual renewable term is much cheaper at
the front end but you would think it'd
be right in the middle for 20 years if
you took a 20-year graph and it goes up
every year for 20 years you're right in
the middle would be the 20-year average
right and so it would average out
exactly the same no it's cheaper for the
insurance company to cover you and they
pass that savings on so the cheapest way
to buy life insurance is a 15 to 20 15
or a 20-year level
term policy uh now if you only need the
policy for five years uh for instance we
were building a uh
a a 25 million dollar building next door
okay
and uh we're about halfway through that
building and my wife goes when if you
die
which she does every so often what if
you die
and so we went and bought a five-year
10 million dollar policy
uh she we had the money but she wanted
to make sure that building didn't burden
her little self
with the other stuff she didn't want any
of the other stuff that we'd laid out
messed with because of that building and
so the com so that was a business reason
to buy a shorter term but in most family
situations you're trying to get the kids
grown and gone get the house paid off in
15 years
and you're trying to build some wealth
so in 15 years you become an everyday
millionaire your house is paid off and
the kids are grown and gone in 20 years
or 15 years right like you got little
ones what age one and three one and
three so 20 years from today you have a
21 and 23 year old something happens
you'll be they'll be okay they can make
it they can make it you'll have enough
money for them finish out college so a
20 year will be just fine for you 15
could leave you a little bit shaky
right but you don't need a 30 because
you don't need to cover your family for
a 31 year old being at home because they
need to leave right you know so there's
that right so that's what we're doing
and so it gets the kids in and out out
of the grown and out of the house which
is that way the spouse that's left
behind is taken care of
uh and it doesn't take as much because
you only have kids to raise right now
you're at the highest point of insurance
need you'll ever have in your whole life
right at your point and me i'm at the
lowest point
uh no responsibilities in a big pile of
money there you go i mean so i'm at the
lowest point right and so sharon's
perfectly fine we don't we don't need
term life insurance but a term is for a
term and that's what we recommend 15 to
20. go to zanderinsurance.com
z-a-n-d-e-r
xanderinsurance.com they're an
independent agent they'll shop a
bazillion of these term companies get
you the best deal
on a 15 or a 20. you got a 10 year old
and 12 year old you need a 15-year
policy you don't need a 20. right and
the goal is after that 15 to 20 years is
you're basically self-insured right like
you've got enough in your account that
if anything happens your spouse is taken
care of and it's not an emergency yeah
20 years from today
um something happens to your husband
something happens to you
the house is paid for because you're on
a 15-year mortgage or less right okay
the kids are grown and gone
almost no liability there
okay financial liability okay and you've
been investing in your 401k for 15 years
so you got 700 800 grand
so if you die at 50 years old and the
kids are grown and gone everything's
paid off and there's a pile of money you
become self-insured by getting out of
debt and investing and so you've done
away with your permanent need for
insurance you need permanent insurance
the only people say that are people that
sell that crap
the only permanent need for insurance is
your agent's need for a commission
they're always they always have that so
we we want you to get 15 to 20-year
level term it's what i had when my kids
were little it's what you've got now i'm
sure
um and it fits with your stage of life
and what's going on and that's what you
look for but term insurance is for a
term if it's one year term it's one five
five
ten ten renewable not renewable almost
all term insurance down days is
renewable
the only question is whether a medical
is needed and it almost and it all will
go up
upon the renewal so if you keep a
20-year level term and then you want to
renew it it's probably going to be
cheaper to actually go buy a new policy
that was going to be my question is it
better to just get a new policy at that
point because they jack what they had to
do is they had to estimate the rate 20
years ago
when they wrote the thing
and the rates every year have come down
and so it's probably a higher rate than
a brand new policy
because every year they've adjusted the
actuarial tables
uh and term life insurance has been
progressively over 30 years of doing the
show it's gotten cheaper not every
single year but over time it's gotten
cheaper because
people are living longer they're
healthier in general i mean i know we
can argue about that but i mean overall
the the average death age is older
and the tables they were using 30 years
ago to write these things were from the
40s and 50s
and now they're using tables from the
70s 80s 90s and so you got a lot
different situation do you have any
recommendations or encouragement for
somebody who has a pre-existing
condition or has had some medical
history
call xander and make sure
that your assumption that it's gonna
mess up your insurance is true
okay
because a lot of stuff that they
wouldn't cover you couldn't get an
insurance cover somebody that was five
years uh clean of cancer you couldn't
get it 30 years ago now you can get it
okay that kind of thing so sometimes
people think things that will keep them
from getting coverage make sure you
actually can't get coverage and then
deal with that situation but you'd be
amazed the number of people they will
cover now and in what situations two
biggest problems you got out there right
now and getting covered is smoking and
obesity
and these are like rampant and that
messes you up messes up your rate big
time double triple as much this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
open phones this hour
christina ellis ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage nate
and jamie are with us hey guys how are
you good how are you dave this is great
we are so honored to have you where do
you live hudsonville michigan and what
is that near it's just outside of your
favorite city grand rapids i love grand
rapids you're right very cool well good
to have you guys visit nashville thank
you thanks for being here and how much
debt have you paid off we paid off 118
000.
and how long did this take it took us 24
and a half months 24 months i love it a
solid two years and your range of income
during that time 80 to 128 000 cool what
do y'all do for a living i'm in sales
i take care of it also with severe
mental disabilities
okay cool it's so good to have you all
thank you thanks for being here so what
kind of debt was this hundred and
eighteen thousand dave we paid off the
house no way
looking at weird people
normal is broke and mortgaged to the
hill and you not you two you're weird
you are paid off baby done
wow and they're young how old are you
guys i'm 33 i'm 31. oh my god and i paid
for how you're super weird i like it so
uh how much is this house worth uh it's
about 360. i love it how much you got in
retirement about 125. all right man half
a millionaire on your way to being baby
steps millionaires hopefully by 40.
beautiful
you're right on track very well done
all right tell us a story what happened
two years ago and uh how'd you get
connected to all this ramsay stuff yeah
so really this all started in high
school um my high school took or had a
financial peace course that i took so
shout out mrs dawson that kind of lit
the fire back in the day oh mrs dawson
like what you did
it kind of lit the fire but as a high
school kid you really don't take all
that to heart so much but it kind of
kind of got me dave ish right so my wife
and i we kind of stayed in minimal debt
i would say but then two years ago i
kept getting emails from my uh my
mortgage provider being like hey do you
want to refinance do you want to
refinance so i actually sat down and
looked at the numbers and realized how
little we've paid off on our mortgage in
the five years we were there and i was
shocked like this is ridiculous we've
paid off seven thousand dollars over
five years so i started looking at what
we make and what we owe and i came home
i'm like we can do this in three years
let's just knock this out
and then it just becomes more and more
infectious i got plugged into the
podcast i would go on walks every day
i'd listen to you for hours just get
super excited at the debt free screams
and just got pumped and here we are
jamie it sounds like you developed a
problem you know
a little bit but
when you're passionate about it you just
keep going so
there he goes
there he goes exactly
that's impressive guys 118 thousand and
24 months that is quick what kind of
things did y'all do to get out of debt
so the big thing for me is i picked up
side jobs there's so much opportunity
out there right now for people to make
more money i did doordash i worked for a
buddy who does fireworks i helped him do
fire professional professional firework
shows i donated plasma really there's so
much opportunity out there just to go
make a little extra money and we were
bringing in an extra 1 000 1500 a week
just in side jobs wow and we did that
for about a year the last year once we
found out we were pregnant with our with
our little laney over there we really
went ham for the final uh
eight to nine months and bring her home
to a paid for house
you betcha yep and i just picked up i
mean at the beginning of kovid when no
one was working i'm in healthcare so i
worked a lot of extra hours like 50 60
hours a week and just
my whole paychecks to go straight toward
the principal and
just and once i found out once i found
out
exactly once i found out i was pregnant
i did cut back a little bit but um for
the most part just
worked many many hours yep and all the
government inflation checks that they
sent us during covet we just put those
right toward the mortgage rights bonuses
there you go countrywide yeah i like it
turn it right at it get rid of it ready
to go you guys
wow y'all are weird
but you're completely
free we are
33 years old and no payments and no it's
an amazing feeling it really is it hits
me at these little weird moments just
like man this is mine i'm here with my
family and my friends and my kid and
like
it's just a sense of peace that i didn't
know was possible it really is you
didn't even know it was missing no it's
so subtle and normalized in our culture
but then when you're free you just look
around and go these poor people they
don't know
the rest of them he mentions that all
the time i just don't no they don't know
you want to grab them and go though well
you get the opportunity to scream your
debt free that'll wake up i don't wake
up i'll wake up a couple of them
hopefully oh my gosh
what do you what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is like i
said for us it was work there's so much
opportunity now especially now there's
all this what's your best job the one
made the most money uh door dashing
delivering food i would have how much
could you make door dashing i was
averaging 25 to 30 an hour doing that
and i would do that most nights and on
the weekend so there was weeks i would
pull on over a thousand dollars doing
just that that's impressive and that's
cool that it's like something anybody
could do so there's no excuse it's it's
yeah you know it's not a second job per
se it's something turned off you can
turn it on and turn it off yep but now
that we're done with all that once once
the baby came and the house was paid off
it's like nope we're just going to go
back to work in our 40-hour jobs and
just enjoy life enjoy each other you got
a lot of time now
oh my god you figure out what to do with
your free time now it's great who are
your biggest cheerleaders in the process
for me it's my best friend kyle over
there uh he's the one who i share all of
life with and uh i think he probably
knows more about my finances than i do
but it was uh it was great to have him
along on the journey and he he could
come along with us today yeah that's
cool that's fun that he made it down
that's yeah yeah great job to you too
kyle yeah excellent excellent excellent
work well you guys are absolutely
incredible you're an inspiration man i
mean this can be
done
wow what a legacy to leave your baby too
you all are going to have so much
freedom moving forward and it's just
what a sigh of relief to have
nothing to worry about no financial
stress you don't owe anything to anyone
that's just a beautiful way to step
forward but i want to be able to take my
daughter on trips and be able to see the
world so she can make her world view on
what the world really is right instead
of who's screaming the loudest on
twitter who's screaming a lot of us on
facebook if she can see different
cultures meet different people and build
that world view from her actual personal
experience based on what she sees from
social media
i think that's what really excites me
about this that we can yeah we can be
free and we can go live and we can go do
things and not have to worry about how's
that mortgage going to get paid it's
just it's an amazing feeling and she'll
probably discover what the rest of us
have that uh whoever screaming the
loudest usually has the least to say
that's great you guys are incredible
very very very well done this is
beautiful fabulous fabulous you
mentioned a trip do you have anything
planned uh not yet she's a little young
um
we're hoping she's a little older maybe
go to mexico or europe or wherever
really that's anywhere anywhere you want
to go anywhere we want to go don't have
a payment in the world no
there's a lot of the financial piece
it's it always works now you connected
ramsey you said through the podcast
yup mainly the podcast and then i did
sign up for the free trial of ramsey
plus and i took the uh we took the the
class there just to kind of refresh it
so you've been oh you've been through
financial pieces yes we were at high
school you said yes yep yep it was kind
of a slacker course at the time but i'm
glad i took it it really it planted that
nothing against you dave but i planted
that seat
i'm a slacker
but when i planted that seed as a high
school kid that really just stayed with
me for the past 20 years and i'm so
thankful that i did take the time to
take that course it really changed the
whole projection of our lives well what
it did is it made you want it made you
wonder if you could be debt-free and
most people don't even wonder about it
and later on you went wait a minute i
think there was a guy said i could do
that
yeah the funny ones are the tweets from
the kids in the class in high school i
read one this morning it's like coach so
and so don't do nothing all he does is
turn on these dadgum dave ramsey videos
and walks out of the room my real
teacher is a video it's like hilarious
but i think there needs to be more of
that in high school like kids aren't
taught that they get into the real world
with college that like with you
christina they get into the real world
and they're just they just don't
understand what it means and what it all
takes to pay these debts off in these
loans and i had that seed planted to me
then so i was fortunate enough to
graduate college debt-free she graduated
mainly debt-free so we started off on a
good a good forward step and just kept
going hats off to our foundations and
personal finance crew here that puts it
in high schools 48 percent of the high
schools in america i'm now taught it so
it's good stuff all right nate and jamie
and laney we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you that is the next
chapter in your story copy a total money
makeover for you to give away get
somebody else started and another year
to financial peace university membership
the new videos are on there you can give
that to someone get them started because
i'm sure
uh you people are uh have heard you talk
about this i bet so there you go nate
and jamie and laney hudsonville michigan
118 000 paid off in 24 months house and
everything they're weirdos making 80 to
128 count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three
two one
[Applause]
[Music]
looks like she's ready to go to mexico
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
christina ellis number one best-selling
author ramsey personalities my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
your life and your money nelson's in san
francisco hi nelson how are you
hi dave how do you do better than we
deserve sir how can we help
i have to say dave first of all it's
such an honor to have gotten the chance
to speak to you i started to think where
we would be had it not from being for my
wife and your teachings thank you so
much for everything well thank you
i have a quick question um both marath
and i currently own a very small
montessori preschool here in san
francisco
and
we're very fortunate we have the weight
list and we are
trying to expand it's our first time
looking for a commercial spot here
and you know looking for a commercial
spot also means that um we have to do
the renovation so i was wondering if you
can give us some advice as regards to
the do's and don'ts of lease negotiation
and
just start actually if we should find an
architecture or a designer or a
contractor
well
are you going to try to you're going to
try to rent an existing building you're
saying and um
then just redesign it for the use of the
school right
correct so we have to do the soaring the
floor plan the bathroom for the children
[Music]
okay well obviously
uh
the more time you spend shopping the
more likely you are to find something
that is closer to usable
that requires the least renovation
that's our best bet
okay
if you're moving into a typical
commercial setting um
they're going to lease it to you and
include a certain amount of ti
tenant improvements
and so
yeah so like we own commercial property
that we lease out and when we lease to a
tenant we'll give them so many dollars a
square foot of ti
for a three year lease more dollars per
square foot of ti
for a five-year lease in other words the
landlord is putting up a lot of the
renovation costs and for in the form of
tenant improvements built into the lease
now obviously i i is the landlord i'm
going to recoup that out of you in rents
during that time but it's our way of
investing because a lot of small
businesses like we own some strip
centers and stuff like that that have a
simple bay in them and a lot of small
businesses that want to rent out in that
bay don't have
three hundred thousand dollars to
renovate it
okay so we might put in
depending on the lease terms and
whatever i mean we might put in a
hundred thousand bucks or something but
that's then built into or capitalized
into the lease we get our money back
over the period of that lease and we get
rent so it's built into it but that's a
normal
carrot to dangle
for a commercial landlord to draw in
someone is a certain amount of ti and
what i would be looking for is a
situation where the t i will cover your
renovation
and so let's see you know uh uh and
a lot of landlords uh have a you know
they have a a a
contractor to do the renovation a
designer to do the renovation in their
pocket in a good way in other words it's
handy like i've got a guy we use it most
of ours in most of ours and so if you
want to do that we'll just go okay so
and so over here he can roll in there
and throw up those studs put in the
dance floor for your dance studio or
whatever it is and this is what it's
gonna you know he runs out of bid on the
restrooms the way you want them in this
situation that aren't or that way they
have to be modified to fit your
situation with children going to be
there and so forth and all of that added
together then we added up and go okay
there's the budget well our ti covers
all but
20 000 of that and you got to come up
with that extra 20 and we cover the
first whatever you know as the landlord
and that's that's really the way you get
into the lease and and but again if i've
got something there
uh that um
okay i have a
uh a daycare in one of ours okay
and if that daycare were to move out and
you were to move in
there wouldn't be a lot of retro
as a matter of fact if you really wanted
to tough it out you could probably just
move in and what i would have put up as
ti i can give you his discounted rent
then because i don't have to write those
checks for your construction to get you
as a tenant so i'll just give you some
discounted rent as a result
um
and that's not unusual so i'm really in
your case looking for something more
like that than i am this massive
glorious
uh glass box somewhere that you start
from scratch and have to draw up and
build every little element of it because
that gets really expensive dave what's
the best way to search for a commercial
property to rent is it through a
traditional real estate agent are there
certain people that can help you a
certain place to go
commercial real estate agent
and again
they specialize a lot of those a lot of
them make their living on leases just
like this and they get paid by the
landlord a percentage of the lease
uh commission
uh you know
when the lease is built out and so we'll
pay if a
real estate agent has brings us as the
landlord
a tenant we do the tenant improvement we
pay them so we get a lot out of pocket
to move somebody in there
uh in a lot of cases but um
yeah the cu there are commercial agents
that don't do any houses
and all they do is make their living
leasing space
okay and it's a pretty good living if
they're in a situation like you know
he's out in san francisco that's some
high dollar stuff and
you know if you're working that they may
be exclusively that they may not sell
property at all
they may only work leases uh it's not
unusual at all in a market that size to
find people that make their whole living
doing that in a very specialized way but
what you've got to do you got to go out
there and kick the tires and turn over
the rocks and find you know be shopping
and calling and messing around poking
around um to find the thing that's the
best fit because if you just go to the
again the gleaming shiny glass box and
go from ground up it's going to be
expensive it's going to be very hard to
make the move and you're trying to
expand your business at the same time
trying to make a bigger school
so very very very difficult
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five linda's in omaha
nebraska hi linda how are you
i'm good dave we love your show and your
people and you and all that thank you
ma'am how can we help
okay just curious um
what percentage should your residential
rent be of your income
if you're 75 with no debt and in good
health for 75
score good for you
still living
still kicking around yeah right
just you know with the way the rents
might be going up and
all that no they are going up
well you know you you so i said like 25
exactly yeah we usually recommend that
you don't spend more than 25 percent of
your take-home pay on housing just that
you still have that flexibility in your
budget to do other things and not be
strapped
yeah and um
why have you not bought something
well i have that but
with my age i wanted to get you know
just down to some simple apartment
[Music]
well won't you get down to something
simple a condo that you own
well
that's just
that's a thought that's a thought do you
uh you have
what's your net worth
um around a million good for you
good for you good job linda are you
selling a house or what are you doing
yeah
well how much you getting out of the
house
not much
okay so you're going to use you'd have
to use some of your million to buy a
condo what can you buy a decent little
one-bedroom condo that you would have
rented
anyway in omaha for
i don't know i really haven't looked at
that i was just figuring what percentage
of income
and the income fluctuates but here's the
problem okay statistically
since you're 75 and in such good shape
you're probably going to make 90.
oh
and that's 15 years of rent increases
yeah
and i i'm not i'm that you know your
largest item on all of us in our budget
is housing
in most cases and if housing if your
largest item is going up every year for
15 years i mean think back 15 years when
you were 60 oh yeah what rents were
i see i don't want that to happen to you
in the in your last 15 20 years or
whatever it is you got uh so that's why
i'm saying if you buy a little condo
you're locking it in no more cost
increases
yeah i should just say you're free
you're you know you're the only thing
that's going to increase your hoas will
go up your you know taxes insurance that
kind of stuff you can't keep that from
happening but the actual monthly rent is
going to increase when you are a renter
so long term renting is i mean
that's assuming you're going to make it
that long but you sound like you're
doing pretty good
with a net worth of a million dollars
she could buy that in cash too yeah if i
buy 150 200 000 condo in omaha you'd be
in pretty good shape
and that's pretty simple
and you've locked in your costs that way
that's what i think about
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramsaysolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships
thanks for jumping in america we're glad
you're here christina ellis number one
best-selling author ramsey personality
is my co-host open phones triple eight
eight two five five two two five
catherine's in ocala florida hi
catherine how are you
good thank you how are you
better than we deserve what's up
so i have a question um
my husband is currently enrolled for
fall semester down at ucf
and we are trying to cash flow college
because that is the one thing that we
haven't taken debt out on is a student
loan
so we're trying to continue that um
and my question is
would it be a
smart decision wise decision however you
want to state it
to
sell our house
and
rent
for a couple months
to get the equity out of our house pay
off
all of our debt and be able to cash flow
all of his college
how much do you owe on your house right
now and what's your monthly payment
um it's we owe 111
000 on our house
and our monthly payment right now
um with
homeowners insurance and all that stuff
is uh 1100.
okay and how much is the house worth
the house is worth right now
comps in the area are going for 285.
i mean 1100 a month is a good payment if
you were going to rent somewhere how
much do you think rent's going to be
it would be
roughly right now we're seeing about
hundred a month
um but the only reason why we thought
about doing the renting was because then
all of our
credit cards would be paid off our cars
would be paid off everything so then it
would actually lower our monthly
expenses in that area how much debt on
those things
um total is 82
okay and what do you own your cars each
you won't be happy
so one is 50
and 1000 and then the other one we owe
12.
okay and what's your husband studying
engineering
we have four semesters left
four semesters of engineering live and
what do you make
um i right now make right at 60 a year
he's he works full-time and goes to
school full-time i work full-time
i am a night shift nurse so the only
question is because you've got all these
payments you can't pay for tuition
that's what's changing that's what's
jamming you up right
yeah i mean so what if i said you're
selling the wrong thing
what do you mean
well a 50 000 car does not fit in this
equation
correct
so sell the stupid thing
i mean your payment's what 900 bucks
it's almost as much as your house
payment
not quite 800. um
yeah it's seven like 70. the only reason
why we're not is because we would then
be upside down with it
whoopty doopty
770 a month to put you through school
go buy a 2 000 car
um
and let's you know clean out your garage
have a garage sale and start knocking
out some of these credit cards but you
have a car problems all you've got
how much could you sell that car for
how much could i sell it for right now
it's going for about 45. who
said kelly blue book for trade-in
um no for uh like private sale okay so
you're 5k upside down
yeah yeah so run down to the credit
union and get you a 7k loan
buy you a two thousand dollar car and
get rid of fifty thousand dollars worth
of car payments
listen you're trading your home
for this stupid car bad trade
i think the only reason why we'd be
willing to do it listen you do whatever
you want to do but i just told you what
to do i understand i understand yeah you
gonna do whatever you wanna do but this
is what this is what i mean there is no
question the the fly in the ointment
here is not your house the flying the
ointment's not your income
the the flying ointment that the thing
that stands out when you give us your
situation that just stands out like a
sore thumb is this ridiculous car and
you are so in love with it yeah um yeah
that you're willing to sell your home
and move your children
for this stupid butt car
that's what it comes down to you need to
get rid of the stupid butt car well if
you do that you've got about 30 000 left
which that's very doable to pay that off
well you don't have to worry about i
mean you just cash flow that and
basically don't even reduce it just pay
minimum payments on everything get your
butt on really tight beans and rice
budget get husband through four only
semesters left
and everybody work extra jobs no
vacations quit eating out tighten down
your dad gum budget you got 1100 house
payments you can make it on that
and you're gonna be in great shape
you're gonna come out of this thing but
you know there's one thing standing in
your way
i might even sell the other one yeah i
mean that's a lot of car that's a lot of
car and then he's going to be an
engineer after all that so it's like
he's going to have an engineering job
she makes 60k like y'all are going to be
he's working full-time right they got
the money you got the money to do this
you just no you're looking for an easy
way out don't do it please don't do it
you can do what you want to do but you
called here and the problem with calling
here is we're going to tell you what to
do right and and we're right that's the
other thing keep that in mind
yeah maybe maybe not we're probably
right though and uh
[Laughter]
experts on our opinion that we are okay
uh bernie's in sacramento what's up
bernie
uh
just living the dream out here in
amazing conservative california
what how can we help today with your
illusions
yes yes
well i gotta say i'm a big fan
i've always known of you but my wife and
i she's really the one that got us
turned on to the whole baby steps thing
and we've been following it pretty well
um cool what can i say what's your
question today a lot
well
currently uh we're paying off a lot of
our debts and we've paid off around 40
000 out of the 80 000 that we've had
and we are trying to make a decision on
whether or not we should invest money
into our property which would help give
us a more of a monthly income
or put it towards the house and paying
the house off sooner
um
what about the other debts we need to
clear the other debts before we have
this discussion well
no of course of course okay um then once
you've gotten rid of the other 40 000
then do you put money into a rental
property or pay off your house
yes
how much money we're talking about
well uh so i live on just about five
acres and there's two kind of rundown
guest houses and we were our plan is to
remodel them how much money are we
talking about
uh about ten thousand dollars each okay
yeah i would i would do that before i
paid off my house get two rental
properties engaged but only after the
40k is gone and the emergency fund's in
place
now we're down to baby step 456 stuff at
that point and that that's when we would
do that hey good question bernie this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
christina ellis number one best-selling
author ramsey personality is my co-host
today i'm dave ramsey your host a lot of
people would rather spend their weekend
doing yard work than talk about
insurance even in the heat
but here's the deal if you don't take
the time to learn about insurance you're
going to always feel like you're getting
ripped off probably because you are
around here we think learning about
money topics should be simple and hey
here's an idea even fun our new
confidence in your coverage five day
video series with our friend george
campbell
makes learning about insurance quick and
practical you might even laugh out loud
because it is after all george
every day for five days ramsey
personality george campbell will walk
you through a new insurance topic
unpacking everything you need to know
these are quick little videos that teach
you a lot in a short period of time
at the end of the series you'll still
have the artwork but you'll know your
stuff when it comes to insurance george
campbell check it out it's completely
free go to ramseysolutions.com
confidence and sign up for the
confidence in your coverage five-day
video series completely free ramsey
solutions.com
confidence dan's in new york city hi dan
welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
well i need to know if i can afford a
new truck or not i need somebody to give
me the go ahead or knock some sense into
me
[Laughter]
we are specialists at knocking sense
that's what we do around here we're
sense knockers oh my gosh uh so how much
is the truck
it is 52 000
cool what kind of truck
it is a 2019 f-150 limited so we
very nice what do you make a year
uh my wife and i uh we make 242 000 a
year gross uh before a bonus
what's your net worth
our net worth is around 450 000.
excellent and you have the cash for the
truck
uh we do have the cash but i am hesitant
um
to
sp to drop it all i was considering then
don't buy the truck three year load then
don't buy the truck
got it so financing is off the charts
yeah
off the table the here's the thing
here's what i just did
you just emotionally during this
conversation you emotionally
decided whether you want the truck or
not
because you had to pay for it
see what debt is is it's a form of
denial
it's like i didn't really buy it i just
sort of rented it you know that's what
our that's what the psychology of it is
but when you gotta freaking pay for it
and you go i have a 450 000 net worth i
make a quarter million dollars a year
i'm gonna write a 50 000 check for an
f-150 19 model which is a sweet truck
um it is now now you're going
okay but you actually mathematically
from the arithmetic that i heard can
afford it
can i give you one more curveball you
can try
at my my next promotion at work which
would be about a year and a half from
now i get a car allowance for what's
currently 500 a month
car allowances come whether you have
payments or not
uh that's a good point i don't know the
exact details i thought i'd have to have
the loan not paid nope it's a car
allowance they allow because they're
going to run the car that you have in
the dirt please don't drive this truck
unless you're if you're on the road are
you a road warrior
no no i commute to an office it's just a
perk they try to give you oh okay do you
have any debt currently
uh just the mortgage we recently uh paid
off our student loans and my rice car
that's awesome and you have a fully
funded emergency fund
yes we do yeah okay what's kind of your
hesitation
so
let me uh
how do you react when i say
the fact that you want to take out
payments is a form of denial
i get it i've um
i i deny myself things all the time no
no no no no no no that's not the kind of
denial i'm talking about i'm talking
about you're denying that you spent
money
uh
i think that it might be kicking the can
down the line yeah it doesn't register
in your emotions that you freaking just
spent 50 grand for a truck that's the
denial i'm talking about right
right like i'm in denial
type of denial not not i'm willing to
deny myself
you know i'm willing to be in discipline
so that i win that's not what i'm
talking about
sure no i hear you
you you are uh not the spender at your
house your wife is you are the
nerd i would say yes but she's
definitely on board yeah but i'm not
saying she's not on board i'm not saying
she's not mature i'm just saying
taiwan's have trouble with stuff like
this spenders don't i would already
bought the truck
well i know you have the raptor
and it was more than that but i got more
money too so it's a fair ratio but still
you you dude you really ought to go buy
the truck but don't do it unless you're
gonna pay for it okay
okay i mean we
got it i got to do some math to see if
i'm comfortable with reducing i have a
over-funded emergency fund because like
you said i'm the nerd if you're gonna
pay cash for the truck and not damage
your emergency fund
i would buy this truck in your situation
awesome but if you're not going to pay
cash for it i would never buy any kind
of vehicle i will ride a bicycle for
have a freaking car payment again
yeah you know you just don't run into
wealthy people that go you know i've had
a car payment for 40 years that's how i
became a millionaire it never comes up
it never in any of our studies did we
find that right well i mean it's great
that he's such a saver and he's
aggressive with the savings but it's
hard for some people to actually spend
even when they have the money that's a
lot of money it is a lot of money
it's a really nice truck yeah yeah i
mean it's a beast of a truck that ford
is making a great truck and supposedly
they're all going to go electric so you
might want to get one of those gas
puppies while you can but um
i don't know if they're really going to
pull that off or not because that is the
most popular truck in america the 150.
it's it's like a super sales thing for
ford they make a bazillion dollars off
of it
if the bozos take the gas engine out of
that thing
they're going to kill themselves
because who do you think buys trucks
it's not tesla drivers people it's
rednecks okay come on it's not racial
brain really seriously rednecks are
wannabe rednecks
and none of them drive batteries oh my
god so well who knows we'll see how it
works out it's just a marketing thing
for me but um
yeah so know your market know your
market know your market it's not obama
just know your market oh my god so um
not rachel and george and they're
testing it's not rachel and george
neither one of them have got an f-150
now rachel's husband however yeah yeah
he's definitely got a truck
but um so there's one in the family at
least we got that part down with rachel
anyway
yeah yeah it's yeah
so here's the thing with vehicles let's
hit it again our ratio our rule on a
vehicle is
unless you have at least a million
dollar net worth don't buy brand new
because they go down in value like a
rock that's where chevy got that like a
rock okay so they go down in value so
fast
all right rule number two is don't have
a total of all your vehicles
boats sea doos their sisters
uh
motorcycles four-wheelers snowmobiles
cars
zero-turn lawn mowers add up all the
crap you've got with wheels and engines
and if it equals more than half your
annual income
you've got too much invested in things
that go down in value because everything
i just said goes down in value and you
don't get wealthy buying things that go
down in value and investing the vast
majority of your dead gum income and
toys that go down in value i like stuff
with motors i'm a classic redneck
anything that goes wooden wooden i'm
ready to go man but but that but it's
the worst financial thing you can do
and i know people who spent more on
their stupid lawn more than they did
their car oh gosh oh that's definitely a
redneck thing for sure
well and it's not that you can never
have nice cars and nice things it's just
living in a certain way now where you
save and you're frugal so that someday
you can have whatever car you want oh i
drove an incredible car to work today
it's absolutely amazing but it's a small
percentage of my world right that's the
point and so but when you when you got
uh
uh fifty thousand dollar car and your
husband wants an engineering degree
hello you with payments on it you got
your priorities out order right
especially when you make sixty thousand
dollars yeah exactly and so well we
don't know what he made we never got
that part but still it that tells you
that this is screwed up and so the
mantra
you want to identify what middle class
looks like when you drive up in front of
a small
newish house
and has two brand new cars parked in
front of it
this is people who are going to be
middle class for the next decade plus
unless they straighten their dadgum mess
up you drive down these streets to these
new smallish houses they got brand new
cars in front of every one of them like
double brand new cars like double stupid
this is this is people are putting their
money in the wrong stuff
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
health care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
christina ellis number one best-selling
author ramsey personalities my co-host
today in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on
the debt free stage john and emily are
with us hey how are you guys
great how are you better than we deserve
welcome where do you live
indianapolis indiana oh good good to
have you thanks for being with us and
how much debt have you paid off uh we
paid off 300 000 in debt and how long
did this take six and a half years all
right
and your range of income during that
time uh it was about 100 to just about
200. okay 100 to 200. what do you guys
do for a living
um i am a senior claims adjuster for
insurance
and i'm an attorney oh good okay cool
very good what kind of debt was all this
um 260 of it was student loans oh the
attorneys and the senior claims adjuster
it was me let's be honest
i was trying to get you off the hook but
i knew yeah yeah it was me it was the
law school and then uh she had a new car
and uh i had a used car okay all right
how long you all been married um three
years yeah yeah okay but you started
working on it six and a half years ago
yeah probably about four years ago when
he really convinced me to do it so i
would say four years of really truly
living it but
six and a half total okay all right very
cool so tell us the story how'd you get
hooked up with this ramsay thing and
decided to do this after you got married
um well after we got married well in
high school i had taken it through our
church so i had the head knowledge um
must have flogged dicks i went out and
got a bunch of student loans and a used
car mm-hmm
we um for about a year after that i said
i need to start budgeting i was doing a
budget i was doing davish you know uh a
pitcher of beer with the co-workers
became an emergency and it was
definitely an emergency oh my gosh i
think i had a college emergency for sure
it was
it was terrible i was not really
following a budget i had i knew what i
was supposed to be doing and i was not
doing it and about a year into that
we i discovered i had another student
loan that i wasn't aware of um
and and it was it was more than i had
paid off in the year prior even though i
knew what i was supposed to be doing and
i got i got mad i was mad at the
situation i was mad at myself
and i said never again am i doing this
i've worked harder
than i've ever worked in my entire life
and and and i've just i've lost ground
and that's not acceptable to me i'm done
doing that and right in the middle of
that uh renewed uh enthusiasm i
asked her out on a date
and the end of the story is you get her
but you also got her student loans with
her yeah
i met her it was like our second date
and you know like here's what i'm doing
you know i'm dude i would never again
debt free like this is never happening
and she's like i have a mortgage
like i've got like 240 000 in student
loans and i was like oh my gosh that's
fun i think our second date he told me i
think we could have your student loans
paid off and this amount i'm like whoa
we just met but he already had a plan
real romantic again right yeah
numbers right the second date we're
discussing paying off your student loans
right that's how committed he was i'm
telling you that that's kind of an
informal proposal you got to be careful
with you guys doing that on the second
date but yeah
this is a picture of beer guy too keep
this in mind right yeah
so what really convinced you to get on
board after the second date and you're
like whoa like
um where'd you go well we were engaged
and so i think at that point we were
engaged and he had just paid off his
student loans and so we'd moved in
together at that point and i'm like okay
i need to get serious if we're gonna get
married and go on our honeymoon and have
a baby and yeah so what did the journey
look like because that's that's a lot of
debt to pay off oh it was so long we i i
did mine in two and a half years um i
made her wait uh uh until i got done
with mine to propose
bought the ring we cashflowed to wedding
and a honeymoon
we have a one year or a two one and a
half year old cashflow with a baby we
got a second baby on the way
and we did
so
many things to really cut down on
expenses that was where we went deeper
and deeper and every step of the way
that you go you think
are we prepared to sacrifice x so that
we can get there this much faster and we
did that over and over and over and over
again we moved multiple times to get
cheaper cost of living we
we commuted for two years we commuted
for three hours each for a career
opportunity wow i hate commuting oh
that's oh my gosh it was an hour and a
half in the morning hour and a half and
i got this stink in jalopy that i'm
hauling up and down the highway it's
uncomfortable it's ugly the paint's
missing
a picture of it
we still have
we still do yeah we do and um
you know i planted flowers in it yeah
i want to scrap it blow it up there's
some kind of yeah like army
take it out to some demolition exactly
i'm gonna shoot this with exploding
ammunition test the new missiles on this
thing please just take it oh my lord
and um
you know so we um
it was hard to do it for that long y'all
just sacrificed that's amazing it's
i could have bought a new car and nobody
would have blinked she would have been
she you know anybody would have you
could have made the excuse anybody would
have understood it you're very
disciplined though and um he is very
yeah
and uh so
i i test drove a car three times dave i
got this close man that's good that's
that's bad medicine right there that'll
you start that it's hard to get back
that's a slippery slope once you've done
that it's like oh it was really hard to
not come home with that thing and go
look what i did there was a couple of
them that were really comfortable not
bad
but i'd look at it and i'd say do we
want to do this for this much longer
even if we pay cash for this used car
that's going to push us back this much
longer we've been doing it and and no
the answer is now that you're there and
you're completely free
emily was it worth it oh absolutely
absolutely now that i'm at the light you
know i've reached the light at the end
of the tunnel absolutely without a doubt
yes the journey's a pain in the butt oh
man yes it is
yeah so you said that john
yeah john you said that you took the
class back in high school and it didn't
completely click it kind of like planted
a seed what would you tell the high
school version of yourself knowing what
you know now
um
you can i chose a school that i had a
bunch of scholarships like academic
scholarships i could have chosen a
school
that i had that i would pay very little
or free my brother was in a similar
situation and he went to a college he
chose a college
and graduated with nothing and i could
have done that but there was this other
one that was a little bit shinier i
think they had a travel abroad thing
that i did for two weeks so which
changed your life completely oh yeah it
was worth every penny of that
foreign beer yeah
beer drunk abroad is a big deal
absolutely
and um
so
you got to be smarter than that i i
didn't really think long term about that
decision
um
and uh
that's a good word because so many
students feel like they've got to go to
the fancy shiny school and in hindsight
it's usually not worth it if it results
in thousands and thousands of dollars in
student loans rachel studied spanish
abroad she talked us into this one
semester
um
ask her to speak spanish next time you
talk to her see how far you get
i pick up more spanish in cabo than she
picked up studying abroad right
i can actually order food and stuff and
she can't even get out of the restaurant
it's unbelievable yeah so that that just
that stuff golly man with the stuff we
do all of us man you guys are amazing
i'm so proud of you thank you how does
it feel everybody tell everybody it'll
be completely free john you did it oh
it's amazing it feels so good six and a
half years is a long time to really uh
what happened during that a lot happened
that's a huge amount of life uh that
happened uh we've stayed the course it's
worth it a hundred percent we yeah
that's that's our summer
shot oh man it was great we went to the
lake uh that was one of the things we
did afterwards we got all both sides of
the family we went to the lake um the
kiddo in the adirondack chair all right
we got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you that's the next chapter in your
story you are on your way and a copy of
total money makeover you can give that
to somebody inspire them to move in the
direction you have a freedom way to go
financial peace university uh for a year
membership to that 300 000 paid off in
six and a half years quite a story
making 100 to 200. john and emily from
lafayette indiana or lafayette depending
on where you're from count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream
three two one we're dead
yeah
that's how it's done boys and girls you
gotta love it this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today caroline is with us in
chicago hi caroline welcome to the
ramsay show
hi thank you for having me today sure
what's up
so i um i'm really excited to say that
we are in baby step three we just kicked
a lot of debt to the curb and
looking forward i'm exploring another
master's degree
and i really don't want to go back into
baby step two and so
what are you studying what's your
master's going to be in
um it would be an educational leadership
cool what's the first masters in
um i'm a reading specialist oh good oh
man what great degrees
yeah
what do you want to do with the extra
masters
um
my my own administrators my own bosses
have really been encouraging me to take
this path
um it's something that many have
suggested to me kind of along my career
and i never really thought of it as an
option because we were still carrying so
much debt from our undergraduate and my
first master's degree and so
now that that's behind us it just seems
like these doors keep opening and
i want to be able to to go down to that
next route i love it
what's it called
i think it's going to be about 20 000
for a two-year program which is really
reasonable
i think it's very reasonable and it's a
cohort which is awesome because you just
build a community of learners around you
and again like well they'll be lifelong
friends they'll be lifelong friends
because you're so specialized and
nuanced
and you've got a heart for a certain
thing you'll be you'll be knit together
forever that's wonderful
right
so i've been looking for scholarships
because my own children are about two to
three years away from college themselves
and so we've had a lot of conversations
about going to college debt-free and not
taking on loans and so now it's my turn
to kind of practice what we're preaching
and so
i've been exploring a lot of different
websites and financial aid finders and
starting the process of applying to
different scholarships and
my question is kind of twofold like one
at this point because we are debt free
we are able to kind of cash flow at
least the fall semester
and see where that takes me after it
um but but by doing that we kind of slow
down our process of moving into you know
finishing baby step three and then
moving into you know four five and six
so we have good momentum i don't really
want to slow that down right now um but
most of the grants and scholarships that
i'm finding are really geared towards
undergraduates for understandable
reasons and so i'm wondering
if you
would advise or give any resources
towards graduate program specific
financial scholarships
or would you just say you know what this
is you know a thinking fund and
you know continue the cash flow because
you know because you can
well i would definitely continue to
explore both options i think it's
awesome that you already see that you
can pay for the fall
that you're you're able to cash flow
that and save and also continue to
search for scholarships you said that
your bosses are really interested in you
going back for this program have you
talked to them at all about possible
tuition assistance or helping you out
with that i have that's a great question
i have and
some school districts do have
reimbursement programs are available but
at this time my district does not i have
asked that question
it really comes down to negotiations
between the
district and the teachers union if that
is included in next year's contract or
not so
okay
that's as much as they can do and i also
did ask the university the woman who's
leading the cohort if um knowing that
we're not being reimbursed because there
will be other people in the cohort whose
districts are reimbursing them and so
knowing that my district is not you know
is there any flexibility here you know
or is there any other
um you know wiggle room and she said no
that's a great question though it's yes
i mean i've always said shame on me if i
don't ask you know it's worth giving it
a shot so good good on that um are you
set on a specific school it sounds like
you've already picked the university
i have because it's a cohort and it's
kind of supported you know with um you
know other school districts in my area
what's your household income
um about 250. okay just pay for it
i mean you can search around poke around
for scholarships but you can afford it
right we can i guess what i'm my concern
is um we'll really slow down achieving
like
baby step three no you're right not much
i mean
you may slow down going out to eat but
you're not gonna slow down baby step
three
right i mean you make 250 000 a year
baby step three you knock it out
it's only 20 yeah we hope to be there by
december so
yeah i mean you should be well and it's
20 grand over how much are you putting
in your how much are you putting in your
emergency fund what's your
target uh we want to have about 35 000
in it
okay 35 020 000 to pay for the whole
program is 55 000 out of 250 000.
i'm doing big math here and i'm not
having trouble with this
right
i think we feel really behind our
environment and our own uh you know
students our own college college tuition
for our own you know so here's the thing
okay we're trying to get you through a
two-year program we're trying to get
them through a four-year program that
ain't even started yet
right
and you've got the income to do this
so you may need to you know you may need
to put some distant future things tight
turn them down a little bit turn this up
a little bit and then you know do some
adjustment back and forth but you've got
the cash flow to do all three of these
things send your kids to school yourself
to school and finish the emergency fund
and you've got the money to do it in
short order um but you're going to have
to really look at other stuff in your
budget and go where's the 250 000 a year
going that i can't find 50 grand
and when you do that then you start
going huh there it is and there it is
and oh there it is and we're done we got
that beefed up and that beefed up and
that beefed up it can go away i mean 250
000 you can spend it pretty quick it's
not but but i'm not saying you're being
wasteful or something like that but but
what you are going to do is you know it
might be that we light pedal kiddos
college right now
savings heavy pedal the emergency fund
finish the emergency fund and your and
get your tuition keep your tuition
moving along in the budget and uh talk
to your university again go above the
ladies head that said there's no help
i'm paying cash for this out of my
pocket i want a discount for cash
not i'm pitiful they don't give me
reimbursement dad gum people i'm giving
you money give me a deal
and mess with them a little bit i mean
just bust up into yeah i'm thinking it's
good for higher ed people to hear
occasionally that they're overpriced
right they probably need to hear it more
because a lot of people are struggling
with that and there are grad school
scholarships like you said that they're
a little bit harder to find than
undergrad they're hard yeah it's more
competitive and you know it just takes a
bit of research but on this income i'm
with dave i would say just go ahead and
cash flow because in the amount of time
you're going to spend researching and
applying for scholarships y'all are
making so much money that you should be
able to pay for it yeah i mean if you
want to go searching for some of them
that's fine that they are more of a
needle in a haystack um
i think you're gonna have more
i would call the president at university
and just mess with them
i mean one more time like you said shame
on me for not asking but even if you got
a 10 discount it's two grand it's worth
a phone call
uh but i mean so what's my discount for
cash again oh nothing wait a minute that
doesn't work for me you know and just
have this conversation be a little bit
uh sassy
with it um it's kind of fun
because they don't ever have people do
that and it sets them back on their
heels people go oh i'm so thankful i got
in what i got the opportunity to give
you people money oh i'm thankful for
that you know that isn't that
interesting how we've gotten this whole
thing reversed
so yeah where if you went in to spend if
you were going in to buy a car you'd
negotiate their dead gum hat off you
know i mean oh my gosh
so yeah i'm gonna mess with them and i'm
gonna cash flow it if i'm in your shoes
you do are doing the right thing i love
your degree field i love it's a cohort
like i said earlier i think those will
be friends for life
not just i mean it's like it's like the
best kind of fraternity it you know it
didn't involve over drinking it involved
over studying and so you know this kind
of stuff so it's really good
right and i also i know it's a cohort
but there are other schools that have
cohort programs and some of these other
schools actually have fully funded grad
programs and i don't know where you are
locationally and if there's schools in
that region
but there are a lot of programs that are
fully funded so you know don't get so
sad i didn't go there i'd go find one of
those and wave it under this president's
nose and go hey
i'm about to leave
right got other choices and you're not
it and see what they do yeah one more
thought is you have a master's degree
also look into an edd program because
you may be qualified for that you can
kind of kill two birds with one stone
getting to the next level
that's interesting
i wonder if the state had any
reimbursement even if the local
teachers don't i doubt it
can always look i always turn over some
rocks that puts us hour the ramsey show
in the books
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions it's the ramsay show where dad
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice we
help people build wealth do work they
love and create actual amazing
relationships
christina ellis ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today open phones here at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five zack is in findlay ohio to
start off this hour hi zach welcome to
the ramsay show
thank you sir how are you doing today
better than we deserve what's up in your
world
oh my wife and i have been reviewing our
financial picture and we were curious if
we might be
contributing too much to our traditional
401k and we're curious on your
perspective
okay how much are you putting in there
last year i contributed to the max so 20
500
or 19.5 i can't remember when the change
was but it was the max 6000 of that was
to the roth and then the remaining would
have been to traditional 401k
and then my wife's contribution would
have been 18 000 all going to
traditional 401k
okay
now you can do
roth 401k and a roth personal there's no
pro prohibition on that
sir sir yep and where
what's your household income
well we're at i was just going to
explain that we're
pulling in over 340 a year and so we're
in a position where we can't contribute
to a roth independent of what's offered
through our
employer unless we backdoor it yeah you
can just do a backdoor raw that's what i
do
so okay um um
all right so 20
so what percentage of your income are
you in putting into retirement when you
add it all up have you figured that out
um
not directly
you're doing 20
and she's doing
19 plus 8 no no
she's doing 18 total so our our total
contribution that we're putting in would
be about 38.5 a year
and 15 would be 45.
correct yep
so we need to
yeah so what i mean what i'm hearing in
this is then we would need to be bumping
off
contributions outside of our traditional
then correct yeah i mean we tell folks
that baby step four
i assume you're out of debt and have an
emergency fund right yes sir okay
babysit force 15 of your income into
retirement fives kids college and
anything we can find in the budget
beyond that we pay off the house with
baby step six right
correct yep
yeah you guys are doing great though
that's awesome i think just that little
tweak and you guys are going to be
really set in a good spot what made you
think you were putting too much in
uh when we were projecting out what our
balance is
yep we will and
what
so what this started for us was a
conversation about how do we retire
early yeah and then if all our money is
tied up in some type of program when
that's fair that's it without penalties
then we need to create a gap fund okay
so maybe if
i'm fine with that or bridge fund
whatever we want to call them you know
the 45 how old are you
38 yeah so 45 to
how do i get from 45 to 59 and a half if
i wanted to retire early and get to some
of that money yeah if you want to do
some low turnover mutual funds and call
that part of your 15 instead of doing
the back door roths i'm okay with that
okay but the point being that you're
you're setting aside for your future you
know can i save too much i don't know
can you be too rich i mean you know
um that's kind of what it comes down to
no you really can't because you could
the richer you are the more generous you
can be the more people you can help and
the you know the more margin you've got
and the better your sense of humor is
and all that hypothetically assuming you
had one to start with but yeah the uh
yeah
but the uh uh
yeah i i think you're right um but i
wouldn't say
uh
we're only gonna max out our 401k and
then just dump the rest of it on the
house and only be saving only be saving
you know 10 i'd be saving 15 into
something even if some of its bridge
or gap or whatever whatever we want to
call the fun and just pick your low
turnover mutual fund uh like a um
uh
something like an s p 500 fund where
there's not hardly any taxes on it
because it's all capital gains growth
sure yeah some type of index fund then
yeah that's an easy way and it's no
commission way to get to a low turnover
you could check with smartvestor pro and
have them look at show you some non some
low turnovers that aren't indexes i do
both
uh i got a lot of low turnover money
because i'm maxed out a long time ago on
this other stuff and then i'll use some
of that low turnover money
eventually and go buy a piece of real
estate with it because i like real
estate better than i like mutual funds i
like them both i got a lot of money in
both but
i'm an old real estate dog from way back
so i'm always going to go that way dirt
just excites me it's just ridiculous so
um but that gives you a lot of options
yeah and i love those conversations even
the conversation about early retirement
and the cool thing about working with a
smart buster pro is they can kind of map
that out for you so if your goal is to
retire by 45 how much do you need to be
saving right now
in order to reach that goal that's like
a financial plan and stuff yeah that'd
be cool
that's very wise christina
you know i should have thought of that
g dave
no really i should have that's really
good that's a really good insight
because actually what i'm always doing
is big numbers on stuff that's way my
brain works and if he'll sit down and
actually map the thing out
in detail like you're suggesting it
gives you a whole different track to run
on that my big number math won't do
right so i'm i'm good with that you may
even want to back it down further on
your traditional
if it hits you to your gap or your
bridge goal faster as long as you're
putting 15 of your income aside for your
future
i mean we can define it as early
retirement i mean we're trying to find
it as 59 and a half and beyond
retirement we always want to match first
roth second traditional third uh when we
can
and uh so the beauty of these low
turnover mutual funds
tax efficient accounts sometimes people
call them or tax managed accounts
is that when you do cash it out if it's
sat in there more than a year it's taxed
at capital gains rate
15
rather than tax stat and i mean if
you're making over 400 it's gonna be
more than that but if you're making a
normal income it's it's a low tax when
you do where if you put it in like a uh
like an annuity
where you don't pay taxes on it but you
can get it out later
if you want to screw around with that
you know you're going to be taxed at
ordinary income rate
when you take it out so
uh and that's you know that's the
difference in 30 percent 15 or 35 of 38
15 so it's very tax efficient to do
these low turnovers once you've maxed
out other stuff or when you've got a
short of 59 and a half goal like an
early retirement goal
yeah well at 340 thousand dollars it
feels like they can probably do both
they can do a lot yeah they'll be able
to do a whole lot they will go a lot of
directions here it's impressive they're
doing very well yeah that's a sharp guy
i mean very cool just keep diving into
the plan laying it out and just getting
on it cool
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so christina ellis number one
best-selling author ramsey personalities
my co-host today if you haven't heard
the news the sky is not falling the real
estate world is not crashing it is
slowed down
there's a difference between a slowdown
and a crash here's the thing
if you're at a um
you ever been on one of those uh
things uh uh
nascar experience you get in the car and
you're going 500 miles an hour 200 miles
an hour or whatever it is you go and
then you stop
and you get in your car to drive home at
55
it feels like you're walking
after having gone 200. well the real
estate market was going 200 miles an
hour now it's slowed down to like normal
speed
and it feels like you're walking
you've got your systems in shock and so
everybody's going that's crazy and the
world's coming to an end oh my god put
it on tick-tock and let's see what the
tick-tock economists say because they
know what's going on oh brother jeez
please people seriously
unbelievable calm your butt down
you just got off a nascar ride and
you're just driving home that's all it
is seriously this is cray cray
so that that's what's going on if you
want to know what's really happening
with the actual data
which the data is your speedometer says
i'm going 55 i'm not stopped and i'm not
in reverse
that's what the data tells you your
emotions however are still all hyped up
and geared up because you're in a car
going 200.
so you want a reality check on this you
can go you can watch the replay of our
one hour streaming that we did um
several hundred thousand people i think
it's approaching a half million people
have now viewed this uh if you want to
know what's going on it's all the data
i actually do something i hardly ever do
i completely nerd it out
and i did my professor dave as rachel
called it a routine
but uh you know the
data is where we get these principles
people that we teach it's not we don't
just like let's just make this up it's
not what we do so ramsey solutions.com
reality check and watch the free
free reality check on real estate it's a
free live stream don't miss it okay
question of the day comes from
blinds.com 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you mismeasure you pick
the wrong color they'll remake your
blinds for free free samples free
shipping and win
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more now use the promo
code ramsay to get the best possible
deal today's question comes from sarah
in connecticut my parents aren't helping
me with college funds and i don't want
to take a gap year or go to community
college i have a 3.3 gpa so i'm not
getting any scholarships i have five
thousand dollars saved so far and i will
graduate from high school next year how
do i pay for college with no debt in
these circumstances
well sarah my first question is just why
no community college
that's a lot of states have free
community college at this point and it's
a great way to get started
once you graduate from a four-year
school your employer's not asking you
know did you start at community college
and then go on to a four-year school you
get your four-year degree so it's a
great way to save money i would just
encourage you to maybe open up your mind
to that
beyond that there's tuition assistance
programs which i just absolutely love a
lot of companies are now helping people
not only make an income and pay for
their regular expenses but they're also
helping them pay for college so
companies like starbucks amazon walmart
chipotle dollywood disney these all have
really awesome programs where you can
work get experience and pay for college
so you know one of the first ones i run
to was ups oh in louisville they they if
you work for ups loading trucks they pay
for your school
that's a hundred percent well they pay
well yeah
you know so you load trucks make good
money it's hard work 20 hours a week and
you go to school full time
and they pay for it that's pretty
freaking incredible i mean the whole
thing yeah it's like so shut up i mean
join ups it's not it's not the army it's
big brown load the truck man i mean come
on
that's incredible yeah and i mean their
hourly rate is great so it's like this
is a win all of these a lot of these you
mentioned that are 25 30 an hour and
they'll pay for school or a portion of
tuition anyway there's a bunch of
because they're having a higher they've
got hiring problems and so they're doing
stuff to get people in the door
and you're you're in a you're in yeah
i'd also just challenge you on the idea
that you're not going to get any
scholarships there you go yeah because
3.3 gpa like you're still in the running
um a lot of scholarships they're not
just looking for perfect students
there's a lot of niche scholarships in
different areas so their scholarships
are pretty much given away for
everything at this point they're
vegetarian scholarships there's this
amazing golf caddy scholarship where
they give away full ride scholarships
for being a golf caddy there's a
scholarship for having the best peanut
butter sandwich recipe so no
who is that by like jiffy or somebody i
think it is
peanut butter companies that's pretty
cool
so there's scholarships for almost
everything and the thing that i want to
encourage people to think about is that
scholarships they're given away by
people like a lot of people create
foundations that then they create a
scholarship and a lot of people who are
super successful down the road they
didn't have perfect grades in high
school so they're open to picking people
to who are similar to them they want to
pick people who maybe you know have
incredible potential but don't
necessarily have hundreds of millions of
dollars of scholarships that are not
income based they're not academic based
and they're not sports based right and
so the hundreds of millions and they're
not just for perfect students um so
don't write probably actually a
scholarship for not perfect students
yeah i actually saw one probably named
that there there's actually a
scholarship out there that was for
average students i saw one recently that
it's like you had to have a c average to
apply for that scholarship
[Laughter]
that's beautiful
well but but the guy who created this
scholarship
right cause he figured out it wasn't
where he went to school
so um
hey sarah i'm gonna pick on you a little
bit too
i don't want to take a gap year or go to
community college
i just want to go where i want to go and
it doesn't matter if i have to borrow
money listen um this sounds a little
whiny
you know go get some scholarships get
three jobs
or both
or go to community college
but don't try to box it into where you
only way i get to live my dream is
you're being a drama queen kiddo i mean
there's a part of that in this i'm
reading in there um
you know you start telling me all the
things you don't want to do and that you
can't do because you've only got a 3.3
and all of this leads up to the only way
i get to do what i want to do
is the in these in my circumstances that
i've boxed myself into well
don't have to right well and i mean
that's a huge factor that's at the core
of the student loan debt crisis
number one problem yep is college choice
yep
where you go to school is it causing i
mean university of tennessee
12 000 bucks a year
tuition
vanderbilt
how much
like cost of attendance is around 70
000. yeah but i mean tuition this year
56 000 i think yeah okay
and
vanderbilt's great school
uh and if you got 56 000 or you got
scholarships like you did yep you went
and got a degree there
they but it was all paid for by
scholarships that's all great that's
fine
but if you're writing a check for 12
versus 56
and you think you got something for the
difference in 12 versus 56. vanderbilt
you didn't
or even worse if you're taking out
student loans because i graduated from
tennessee and people that work for
vanderbilt went to vanderbilt worked for
me
so you didn't get what you thought you
were gonna get there on people that's
just how that works all right so
you know there's a trade-off in other
words and this idea that you go to this
famous school and it's like all right
we're into suing so and you have to say
have to wear an ascot you know or some
kind of crap that's just bs all right or
i want to go across the state line
because the school has pretty trees
on the campus
one girl actually told me that
she said the campus at the university of
mississippi is a beautiful campus it has
big trees
you're kidding me this is how you select
your academic endeavor
there's a problem here child where is
your parents i love my time at
vanderbilt no it was i'm not my
tradition vanderbilt free if you can pay
for it absolutely if you can pay for
your dream school
debt-free awesome but if it involves
student loans or if you're backed into a
corner like this
you've got to think about we got a we
got a family member that was
valedictorian or salutatorian whatever
got a free ride advantage for undergrad
went on to build a very successful
lawyer it's a wonderful school i'm not
mad about it but don't please tell me
with a straight face that it's worth 5x
to go there what it is to go to your
in-state school that's complete bs
so school choice
matters a lot like community college
sarah so yeah no that's me picking on
you kiddo because i love you this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
christina alice ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt-free stage timothy joins us
hey timothy how are you hey dave great
thanks for having me i'm honored to have
you sir where do you live i live in
columbia missouri oh fun great welcome
to nashville how much debt did you pay
off sir
right around 300 000 in about six six
and a half years good for you man well
done and your range of income during
that time oh 110 125. okay what do you
do for a living uh nothing i'm retired
[Laughter]
nice were you are you you make 125 while
you're retired well just just retired so
okay what were you doing what was your
career i started in engineering i became
a manager and i polished off a 22-year
teaching career oh so very good good for
you well done so i'm going to guess and
say with that amount of money over that
period of time you paid off your house i
did oh look at a weirdo way to go man
thank you how what's this house worth
these days i'd say it's about four and a
half good for you how much you got in
retirement
uh
three three point two
thus the retirement i like it
so uh how much of this did you inherit
uh none i had a few gifts along the way
my folks were very very gracious in
giving me a property that was distressed
that i fixed up and
turned into a rental property and i've
sort of picked that up and done that for
30 years and that's been my side hustle
in addition to my professional working
career so what was that property worth
that they gifted you well at the time at
the time at the time it was about 50.
okay so you're not a millionaire because
of that
no a multi-millionaire
right you're a multi-millionaire because
you're systematically saved
right that's correct yeah okay just want
to make sure because people say all
millionaires inherited their money and i
just want to make sure that people
realize that you are not there because
of that you got a nice gift that was a
nice thing but it isn't the reason
you're where you are no i i took that
property and it was distressed and
turned it into a winner so yeah
absolutely but you know the skills i i i
did that with came from my parents who
were in real estate and and and
had managed properties themselves and so
i saw the picture of you mowing uh
as a kid yeah youtube that's pretty much
how i started my life
before i became a you know so you want
your kid to be a millionaire teach them
to work
oh there it is okay
who knew
well i'd say you know the best summer i
ever had was probably mowing lawns and i
remember walking home with a hundred
dollars in cash
uh when i was you know probably 19 years
old and i just thought what that was
when uh i think
in 1979 i think the minimum wage was 235
265 and
i'm teaching swim lessons during the day
and then you know mowing lawns in the
afternoon and walking home with 100 cash
and that's like three paychecks for a
lifeguard yeah so when i was a little
kid i was like 12 or 14 i was a math
nerd so i'm as bad as you i'd be mowing
grass
and while i was mowing i would increase
the speed
so because i wanted to i wanted to earn
more than three times what my buddies
were making flopping whoppers at burger
king right and i said if i'm i'm not
going to be a whopper flopper i'm going
to learn i'm going to make three times
the minimum wage so i've got i've got to
cut this grass at that speed and so i'm
doing the math because i'm a math nerd
while i'm mowing and weed eating i got
to get finished at a certain time that
way i can get my 3 3x of burger king
wages
that's how it all starts right yeah i i
kept side hustling like that i mean i
manage three rental properties and
i do most of the work myself and and
mowing is a just a great reward it kind
of takes me back to my roots and like
why i got into this i mean you're a
better man than me i quit mowing man
yeah i quit i just don't know i mowed
enough grass by the time i was 18 never
have to do it again god said you don't
have to well when you spend your days
inside a classroom or on a computer it's
grass it's a release it is it's really
nice to get out but
working for yourself is is certainly the
way to go i think how old are you
i'm 59 wow you did so good yeah your
story is impressive what would you tell
people is the key to getting out of debt
and to also save as much as you have
i i think the journey needs to be
purposeful like for me it was like
take responsibility for your happiness
and don't blame others and
um you know own failure uh learn from it
study it and just i always felt like if
you know your weaknesses more than your
strengths that you're
you're you're you're on the path to
improving and and i also felt that
um
part of part of the journey is is for me
like i began my journey as a
an engineer and i was i
pay i just wanted money yeah and then
i got into management and i wanted power
and prestige and those are both very
addictive and elixir uh sort of rewards
but
as you grow older i think you have to
reshape
what you work for for me it became play
and purpose like
what is teaching what you're doing now
for fun i quit well i i retired from
teaching so what do you do now for fun i
manage rental property and i just sort
of like you know uh
i potted with my parents during the
pandemic and we became best friends and
now it's like every day is about
what we can we can do to sort of have
fun and and play and have purpose and
then i just
i i just reflect on that sort of journey
of what the rewards of work are for but
you also i think it's important to enjoy
your work too and enjoy the journey and
whether it be okay money is great uh
power's great
prestige is great but for me it ended up
with play and purpose and creativity i
think teachers i think spend a lot of
time
with purpose but the playful way do you
remember when you were young you just
learn for fun that's sort of what i
thought was teaching was all about and
so i i really enjoyed my career but this
this kind of wisdom you need to be doing
something to share it dude
you need to be doing something somewhere
you don't have to get back in the
classroom i'm going to send you back to
work but oh my gosh you've done so well
and you got to share some of these
messages this is very good thank you
very well done
very very well done how's it feel to be
3.2 million in zero debt
uh it feels like i thought it would i
mean i think i think when you're young
you imagine your future self and when
you get to be this age
you
you reflect on your past self like the
childhood you had and so those two i
think sort of are talking to one another
right now saying yeah i knew i was going
to be you and yeah i knew i was you
and it's this
play and purpose are they they go hand
in hand i mean when you do things for a
reason and you give to others and you
teach them how to overcome
sort of their
fear of failure and and how to find
their way and achieve things and and do
it in a creative way like you do it's
it's it's
it just it gives back to you when you
give that way so i would just say that
uh it's been a wonderful journey and i
i'm looking forward to the next chapter
which whatever that would be i'm looking
forward to your next chapter i think
it's going to be awesome man you're
you're amazing you're a hero i'm so
proud of you thank you very much well
done hey we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you you are one and uh
you will read about people just like you
and you can give it away to show
somebody that this is uh this is how
it's done because you you are a classic
example um you're above average example
but well done very well done so much
wisdom yeah and a copy of a total money
makeover uh you can give that away and
inspire somebody financial peace
university we'll give you a uh one-year
membership to that as well and i would
imagine i see you giving that away as
well so you never know where you're
gonna thank you able to spread this
wisdom very well done timothy beautiful
job man you're you're a stud absolutely
cool all right count it down 300 000
paid off in six and a half years making
110 to 125. let's hear a debt-free
scream three
two one
i'm debt-free
[Applause]
okay don't miss that
number one career
in the largest study a millionaire has
ever done that we did at ramsey airtight
research number one career
more than any other career showed up for
millionaires was engineer
number three
was teacher
he was both with a 3.2
million dollar net worth don't miss this
don't miss it okay there's there's a
lesson in there you don't have to be an
engineer or a teacher but what is it
about those people they're processed
people they stick to a system they work
a system and that and they don't
question the law of physics it works
this way do it this way this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today first thessalonians
1 3 we remember before our god and
father your work produced by faith your
labor prompted by love and your
endurance inspired by hope in our lord
jesus christ
christopher reeves said
once you choose hope anything
is possible christina ellis ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author is my co-host today cameron is in
houston hi cameron how are you
hi dave hi christina thanks for taking
my call sure what's up
uh we're on baby steps four five and six
but i feel like we're a little stuck in
neutral my wife is very concerned about
using a financial advisor um she thinks
she's heard too many horror stories of
people
losing everything from other people
handling their money but i've told her
i'm i'm in need of additional guidance
and and i want to maximize our finances
moving forward
um do you have any advice for helping a
sway for concerns or anything that i
could tell her or discuss with her that
might help us move forward i love
that she's cautious about this
okay there are two kinds of fear
fear that keeps you from playing
kickball in the middle of the interstate
where there's 18 wheelers
or touching a hot stove
those are good fears
right
and you know fears that make you wary of
crooks are good fears
um and i will tell you this truthfully
the thing that scares me more than
crooks are well-intentioned ignoramuses
that are enthusiastic
they will screw you up with money more
often and and screw you up in life more
often than actual crooks because there
are more of them um right
and so i love her caution in that the
other kind of fear is false evidence
appearing real i once heard about a
family that had a car wreck and so i
refused to drive a car
okay that's where she is
okay okay so how do you solve that for
someone that has this fear that is um
based in
it that is based in a good kind of
cautious wisdom but has gone too far the
only way i know to solve it is with
information
now the way i would do that is this
if it was my wife i would say okay you
know what i completely understand
because by the way i do i can say this
truthfully i completely understand that
people sometimes get completely ripped
off by people in the financial world
because sometimes they do
but i do know there are some good people
in that world that also help people and
i don't know how to do this without some
help and so what i'm asking of you is
not that we invest money with someone
not that we make the decision to use an
advisor but that you agree
to do
three meetings
with advisor with an advisor or advisors
to learn about
that industry
because you and i don't know about it
all i'm asking you to go is to listen
and to learn if at the end of that you
remain completely opposed to it then
we'll deal with that
because here's the thing there's more
regulations on those guys dude than
there is on banks
oh wow okay i mean they are so regulated
at the yin yang it's unbelievable i
don't know how they get any work done
for the stupid feds sticking in their
ear hole all the time
it's nuts okay i mean they have to give
you a prospectus that says you're going
to lose all your money in the first 17
pages before you can even see the actual
investment analysis behind it
and this is a this is an investment
that's been open 85 years and has not
had but five down years but you still
have to say you're going to lose all
your money and they say and they make
you say stupid butt stuff like uh past
performance is not indicative of future
performance of course it is that's
dumber than crap
but they make you say stuff like that
you know of course it is it's not a
guarantee of future performance but it's
the only way you do forecasting in
investments or business you have to use
past performance to do it so anyway my
point is when you get in there with a
good financial advisor and say just tell
them the truth she's scared because she
thinks there's so many crooks in this
business and tell them ahead of time
show us what the safeguards are
tell us how the industry works to
protect us if you're a crook
and if they're offended by you saying
that get out of their office because i
if i was in that business i would love
to have this conversation
and tell the uninitiated how
regulated that world is um
it's it's nuts but anyway all that to
say i think the other thing that'll
happen as a sidebar is she'll see a
human being
that is that she will sense
with her spirit
is a good person or as a bad person
okay and you and you've gotta you gotta
trust her when she says that
absolutely now all of our meetings so
far have been over the phone but we do
have some in-person meetings scheduled
soon yeah so i think this will be a good
uh good way to do it if we show us the
safeguards might be the best way to just
just tell them the truth she does not
want to do this because she's afraid of
all the crooks in the business and the
stupid people in the business tell us
why you're not that or that that's not
meet with our smartvestor pros if you
can dude click on ramsay solutions.com
get with some of them because they will
relish because they have the heart of a
teacher
and this is this is like you're going to
give them the opportunity to do what
they love to talk about
right okay yeah we've done a lot of the
vetting too so we're only going to
recommend people that we trust yeah
hopefully that but it always scares me
when we do that because sometimes people
will go in there and do business with
them just because we trust them i would
rather you trust them
you vet them you get in there but i mean
we vetted them we feel good about them
and one of the things we vetted is
they're going to have the heart of a
teacher
and so just you know what are the types
of investments i should be scared of
what are the types of people i should be
scared of and how does that work and i'm
really scared and i don't even want to
be here i would encourage her to say all
of that
and if they raise their heckles up and
are offended get out of their office
don't use them
okay
okay because i think a good one will say
rise to the challenge on this and go
i
thank you for letting me tell people how
this all works because i don't get to
tell many people how screwed up our
business is by the few crooks that are
out there
because truthfully there's a lot more
crooks in the real estate business than
there are in the financial business
because real estate business is
relatively unregulated
i mean there's a little bit of
regulation but not much and there's not
many crooks in real estate business
either it's there you know you're not
taking people's money there you're just
doing a transaction most the time so but
i mean kylie i think a lot it is so
i mean i mean
and there's a lot more idiots
in the banking world a thousand times
more idiots than there are in the
financial advising world because the
tests are so hard
to get in there number one but number it
just requires a level of intellect to
get in there gray matter and you don't
have to do that to work in a bank right
well i think a lot of people get into
these situations and they feel like
they're being interviewed they sit down
with an advisor a real estate agent and
they feel like oh gosh
but it's like you are still hiring that
person like you get to ask questions you
get to dig deeper yeah you feel inept
because you don't know right i mean
anytime you go into a situation and the
expert is there you feel like like like
you know and i but man i'll tell you
what the best thing ever happened to me
in my life i learned to bow up on those
people
and make them prove themselves and by
teaching me right i'm not you don't need
to be my lawyer if you can't teach me
how we're going to win
you know you don't need to be my tax guy
if you can't teach me why we're doing
this and what's going on
you know i don't have to be as good as
you i don't have to know everything you
know but you got to be able to transfer
the knowledge enough that i get comfort
because i'm not doing it because you
said so you ain't my daddy right you
know i said so bull crap
my money you know we're not doing that
so that's the thing you got to get to
there and i love his wife's spirit for
that reason
i think it'll lead them to really good
solid conservative investments that they
won't get screwed on that's a wonderful
thing so folks you're always looking for
someone with the heart of a teacher yes
if they're condescending
or they're offended
by you asking hard questions
which is a form of arrogance or
condescension
if they
expect you to do stuff just because they
said so
you got the wrong people whether it's
mortgage people real estate people
insurance people
uh
lawyers uh financial advisors you're
looking for the heart of a teacher
around the financial world and i gotta
tell you more people learn how to sell
in the financial world than learn how to
teach
so they're the teachers are harder to
find and that's the only people i work
with the only people i'd tell you to
work with that's good that's good yeah
be willing to look around ask those hard
questions and and really explore for
yourself i love her heart that she wants
to see
that's a good place to be in it's a it's
a healthy there's the unhealthy side of
fear that makes her maybe not want an
advisor but being cautious and going in
and interviewing people that's wisdom
yeah instead of just going i turned it
all over to my man
i think i was definitely the man lost
the money no no you are the man
you you don't turn it over you get
somebody to invite you're in charge so i
love you she's sitting in the driver's
seat man that's awesome good stuff good
job christina today good job to james
andrew zach ben austin in the booth i am
dave ramsey your host we'll be back with
you before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramseysolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
[Music]
you